when I was a real psychic medium I
really wanted to help people I was told
I had a gift from God and that draws you
in right it must have scared you when
you discovered this ability I wasn't
scared until I started seeing scary
things and hearing scary things and
getting touched by demons
did you get that
you did not because I'm not a psychic
and you're not a psychic
my guest today
used to be a psychic that would be Jen
Niza and this episode is brought to you
by genius out more from them later now
I would like to turn to my guest Jen
thank you for coming on the show thank
you for having me so I want to hear your
whole story you were a psychic you are
no longer you grew up
out in New York that's really all I know
Long Island Long Island
how does a nice normal Italian lady from
New York end up a psychic normal thank
you
at least you seem normal
um well in my home Michael we were
talking about Paranormal Activity
um things being moved around the lights
going on and off it was acceptable
um terms like ghosts were being used in
my home my mom's aunt was a psychic
medium she wasn't a professional it
wasn't her job she also was kind of what
people do now
they call it Reiki she was a
self-professing Healer with energy and
so it was kind of something that Mom
grew up around so then when we were
children we grew up around it too it was
in my home and being talked about as a
matter of fact uh my even in the
community a friend of my sisters she's a
couple years older than I am so we were
about 12 13 and she was about 12 13. and
a group of girls got together and they
had the Ouija board and the Ouija board
is still out there today rocking and
rolling in Toys R Us or wherever it is
being sold
and these girls got together and they
did the Ouija board and the story was
crazy they
ask the Ouija board and I don't know if
you want me to explain what the Ouija
board is but I've mentioned it before I
actually don't totally know it's but
it's it's this toy but it's not really a
toy and it's this weird occult kind of
thing where you'll put your hands on the
little dial and it brings you to
different letters and numbers yes and
the only other thing I know about it is
the story of how this thing got patented
is shrouded in mystery no one really
knows where this thing came from and
it's still there I remember I was
walking in Long Island not that long ago
I was walking down the street in Sag
Harbor and I saw that they had the board
in a toy shop one of the famous toy
shops there yeah so okay so you're doing
this weird occult Ouija board type thing
yeah well I'm hearing about this are you
hearing me I wasn't I wasn't doing it
and I was a little bit younger and these
girls got together and you know you
asked it questions which of course what
you're doing is you're invoking demons
when you're doing this right so the
girls asked who would be I'll use the
term unalive
first who would be dead who was gonna
die all right I'm just gonna be I'm
going bold Michael I'm putting it out
there's a couple of New Yorkers here
yeah we are we can be blunt okay good so
um they asked who was going to die first
and
um the the planchette was moving around
and it spelled out this girl's name that
was sitting there a couple of weeks
later she unalived herself
now it's like
um
it's so sad obviously but then when you
hear about that how did it know how did
that but that girl was suffering with
depression and you know I don't mean to
go into you know whole educational thing
but how the demons know is because
they're hovering around
um and they see and so they knew that
girl was vulnerable and susceptible and
I'm sure that suggestion was just enough
to push her over the edge you know we've
mentioned demons once or twice and and
for all of human history everyone
believed in angels and demons and for
the last 60 years we've all decided that
it's not real but I certainly think it's
all real and
one aspect of
demons is
they're not God you know so it's not
that they can read your mind but they
are observant they've been around a long
time they're very observant which is
what you're describing that they kind of
can see these things that you're doing
and and prey on you so so you you're
hearing these who did you hear this from
my sister this is from your sister a
friend who participated she didn't but
her friends did okay yeah so you're
hearing all these things and then where
does the Paranormal Activity fit in in
your house it's your Aunt is involved in
all this stuff well she didn't my aunt
wasn't in our house but my mom grew up
that way so I think that's why it was
acceptable in our home and where my mom
and and I am not throwing mom onto the
bus I oh that's my disclaimer nobody
come at mama she didn't know any better
um she actually brought a tarot card
reader into the house when I was 13. and
that and I had that tarot card reading
and I was like blown away I was like how
do these cards know this how did this
woman know that my friend just came back
from a trip and gave me a piece of
jewelry I know that sounds generic but
she went into the type of jewelry she
went into the whole thing
um okay this is what uh because we just
jumped right into the deep end here but
this is what a lot of people are going
to ask which is with the tarot readers
or someone who says they can speak to
the dead you know like that guy who used
to be on TV John Edwards or uh any
psychic or whatever they're going to say
okay regardless of what I think about
the existence of angels and demons and
spirits and stuff aren't a lot of these
guys just hucksters who are really good
at reading people's cues and using vague
enough language that they say you know
I'm getting a b and you say yes my aunt
Bertha died 10 years ago yeah that's her
that's it right so how much how much of
it is
just hucksterism and how much of it is
tapping into something real there really
are charlatans out there or hucksters
like you say and we're seeing a lot of
them I think on Tick Tock we're seeing
them on the street corners with the palm
readings I was about to say some you
know where my head is the song reading
is a lot better yeah it's so much better
um but what you're describing is a cold
reading so looking for the cues I would
actually say Michael there are more real
psychics out there more real psychics um
psychics that are really communicating
with demons
I would steer people away from the whole
thing of course all together but on Tick
Tock an example would be now they have
all new kinds of divination tools that I
had never even seen before like dowsing
rods and that that's been around for a
while I just never used them dowsing
rods or any other thing that they're
just looking for a yes or no that's
where your huckster really comes in I
mean you have a 50 50 shot I mean come
on you know so when I see that on Tick
Tock I go scroll like I'm not even going
in there to preach the gospel I'm like
you know yeah I mean that is just but
they're still participating in
divination anyway they're still doing it
right they're just pretending but
they're still doing it you know and if
you do bad things ironically long enough
you know it's there's really no
difference between irony and sincerity
exactly so
your family's experience with this weird
occult stuff goes back yeah a little bit
how did your aunt get involved in it
um when I became a psychic medium so
there was a difference between psychics
and psychic mediums what's the
difference well I was one of those
people talking to who I believe were
dead people so just like John Edward
um all psychic mediums are psychic but
not all psychics are mediums so a
psychic like a tarot card reader or a
clairvoyant may not tell you that
they're they're not going to be
connecting with somebody from the other
side those are new age terms but they're
not claiming to bring anybody through so
that's different they're not channeling
a deceased person or a medium I'm
picturing like in medical school you
know you start at General Ed and then
you say okay I'm going to focus on
phlebotomy or something I don't know I'm
going to focus on obstetrics but yeah so
you grow up with this you see the tarot
cards you hear the Ouija stories you
know your aunt's involved in this your
mom's kind of open to it
at what point do you say I'm going to be
a psychic
well right after that tarot card reading
I was getting tarot cards my own tarot
cards my sister got her own deck and we
started doing readings in those decks it
comes with um these little books that
explain how to do layouts and
um certain types of readings like are
you doing past present future and then
the claim is that the card will give you
information and that information about
the card is in this little booklet as
well so the idea is to read the little
book and you know and do these cards but
I didn't have to look at any sort of
explanation of these cards I started
receiving information because of course
the cards know nothing about you it's
just cardboard so you know but you don't
know that at the time you're deceived so
my sister would read the little booklet
and get the definitions or whatever
descriptions rather of the cards and we
will go back and forth and do readings I
mean like it was like it was our job but
it wasn't at that time so
what convinced you that you were reading
something that's real what was because
presumably when you lay the cards out or
do whatever you do with the cards you
know you could either flop and not get
the correct information then maybe it's
okay give it up or so what encouraged
you to keep going
when accurate information was coming out
during those readings it's not just
something that resonates with you it is
something that will be true about you
and that's again because even when you
think about the descriptions of the
cards that was being channeled by a
psychic that's automatic writing so that
didn't come from nowhere that that's
demonic information the descriptions of
those cards so um of course them being
put down in a certain type of a way
really doesn't matter the information is
channeled and something is going to hit
something is going to hit because the
demons are in control of this thing and
they're around and you've already
invoked them the second you took out
that deck that's what you've done so
you're sitting with your sister and
you're you're putting the cards out yeah
do you remember any kind of like hey you
know you're you made out with Jimmy at
the bus stop yesterday what I mean is it
what
can do you have an example of really
taking me back I'm 46 Michael yeah I was
like I assumed you were 29. oh thank you
I was like 15 when we were doing this
between 13 and 16
um but I have a lot of examples of
things that um you know I I did a lot of
automatic writings the cards the cards
were just a stepping stone
um and that's a big thing that people
really need to know what is automatic
writing automatic writing is when you
said I did it with paper and pen and I
would ask a question
um or I would put a name down I did it
for my clients as well and I just
started channeling I just started
channeling information and wrote it
really quickly
um it just started coming right out so
kind of like a reading but on a piece of
paper
and and you're you're not consciously no
it's just going I mean it's kind of like
information is being downloaded they're
not your thoughts it's information
um coming in birthdays names of people
like really names of people not like
who's the M name or whatever like really
names of people really things that
happened in your life
um and I did this for perfect strangers
I used to read people I used to be
getting like X-rays and ultrasounds that
I would just start reading
um the people that the the radiologist
or whoever was doing the test yeah and
that really came to my mind I have to
say when I was when they were doing my
makeup and stuff
rewind when I was a psychic I would have
just busted out into a reading
I thank God free of that
it must have
scared you when you discovered this
ability right I mean it would have would
have disconcerted me if I discovered I
had that skill I wasn't scared until I
started seeing scary things and hearing
scary things and getting touched by
demons because think about the devil
um giving you this power he liked to
have pride he liked to have power right
you have that when you know things
hidden knowledge about people right and
now people are coming to you for these
readings and that's building you up
right they're coming to you they're not
going to God
and and I'm I'm saying that with a lot
of regret trust me and I was a young
person so it wasn't like I was walking
around oh I want to be powerful but it
does give you that power and it's
prideful nothing scary there but scary
when you start seeing demons manifesting
around you and some of the readings I
did Michael were um even though my
spirit guide I added my spirit guide who
was supposed to be filtering because the
belief was that there were good spirits
and bad spirits and then of course you
would use false tools of protection like
crystals and white sage and smudging and
I smudged everything to death what's
smudging so you take white sage and you
burn it and I would it's like a bundle
tied with a little rope and I would burn
it around myself burn it in my room
wherever I went to do readings and the
idea is that it would scare away demons
clear out your space it's still very big
today by the way and of course it
doesn't because a demon doesn't care
about Sage but I didn't know that you
know I had a divination leader she said
just imagine white light around yourself
almost like you know a crime scene when
the body's there and they draw a line
like around the body and that's what she
would tell us just imagine a demon is
not afraid of my imagination no or a
fake light or when I ran a long time
come on you know but I did do that um
anyway
I was at a Halloween party and I used to
get hired a lot around Halloween that's
you know spooky time and bring in the
psychics and this woman
um sat in front of me it was a a group
of people but I offered everybody could
stay in the group together or you could
have a mini private reading and that's
what they opted for and this woman this
is how we were sitting just like this
and I sat and I started channeling and
it felt like a bad spirit and I start
giving the information
it so the demon because we know it's a
demon I didn't know then masquerading as
This Woman's uncle but here's the thing
her uncle shot her and her brother when
she was a child this thing apparently
because I remember I was seeing the
newspapers I didn't know this woman from
a hole in the wall and there was like
this angst building up and now she's
looking at me like I did it because
she's seeing you know she's because I'm
communicating with the uncle which of
course I'm not it's a demon and it's
almost like I could have been out of
this like she's dealing now with the
uncle straight on but I'm not the uncle
it's me hello and she's looking at me
with daggers in her eyes and I just
wanted to get out of there I was sick
for like I don't know a weekend or a
full week after that I felt so sick it
was sickening and Evil
so there is an evil side that some
psychics at the time like myself would
acknowledge but many don't acknowledge
that side of it what was your spirit
guide like oh well my spirit guide was a
Native American man and
um just very strong very uh but strong
but peaceful
seeming again we have to just put that
out there wanting to help me wanting to
guide me
and yeah that's really just the just a
quick answer to that one
and I think if we go back to that
experience I shared with you
um when that
evil
Spirit which was pretending to be that
woman's Uncle who shot her
it's like where where were you then you
know where were you then holy uh yeah
yeah oh man I have pseudo Holy Spirit
yeah see I'm more used to saying holy
spirit that I'm saying Spirit Glide
these good you know I think that's a
better Habit to have cultivated yeah but
you can see how it's you can see how
that happens and then you always have
something to blame or something else to
do but yeah and this spirit guide I
believed watched over my daughter too I
I could see him when my daughter was
little I used to
um heal her when she was sick I would do
which again I didn't take any Reiki
classes but I believed I could heal her
when she was sick and I saw this my
spirit guide standing behind her one day
when she was really sick so I believed I
was covered but then I saw her like here
you saw him in the right behind her yeah
yeah just manifested that way
doesn't look like me and you but I could
see him that's how I knew he was Native
American he didn't tell me it I could
see it yeah yeah
did it work
no no
and it's not because I I was any less of
a Reiki person than anybody else just
because God's in control
yeah not uh Chief demon Chief correct
standing behind you with a feather in
his head right
can you not
actually talk to a ghost meaning I know
there's a big debate are ghosts real or
but there is a ghost in the Bible in in
an example of necromancy where
Saul goes to the witch of end and Saul
says I'm I'm I'm outlawing all sorts of
necromancy and then he himself goes and
says hey call up the ghost of Samuel
yeah and this Necromancer does the
incantation and then seems kind of
surprised yeah and she says wait a
second you're Saul wait hold on you're
not I should that's a ghost there and
anyway there's a long history of
theological debate about the nature of
this ghost but my question is yeah can
can you call up a ghost
uh a deceased person yeah no
no you can't when we die we go to one of
two places dependent upon your
relationship with Jesus of course um so
no and there's a great chasm in between
and of course the Bible tells us that
also if you look at Lazarus and the rich
man Luke 16 you'll see that there's
um a great wall if you will Between
Heaven and Hell between so how I say it
all the time is I'm not bopping In and
Out of Heaven and coming to Earth and
coming to your dream talking to a
psychic and you're not getting out of
hell and coming here either so once
where the Bible actually also says don't
talk to the sleeping they know nothing
don't talk to the dead they know nothing
you are where you are so you're never
ever contacting a deceased person you're
being duped but you're not being duped
because the psychic is trying to of
course minus the charlatans and
hucksters but people like me when I was
a real psychic medium I really wanted to
help people I was told I had a gift from
God there's that little that you know
and that Joy you in right because you're
thinking this is a gift this is so
helpful this person is nice and
compassionate and we're hugging and
crying and I believe that it's your
child coming through I believe it's your
husband or your wife or your grandma and
again I don't know you from Adam and I'm
able to tell you where you were last
week what you were doing who your family
members are how your mom died what she
looked like
um and that's really that is frightening
when you think about it but I wasn't
frightened while I was doing it only
when the seductive it's very seductive
too but both because of the appeal to
Pride and because you think you're
helping someone so the people who come
to you it's because someone just died
they're having difficulty grieving and
so they say I want to talk I I listen I
get it I've loved ones die and I think I
Googled it once I said how do you talk
to the dead I didn't I didn't take it
any further than that but
so and I I don't don't intend to uh but
you're a kid you hear about these things
you play these little tarot games you
then
when does it become a job yeah so
actually that was when the scary stuff
started happening for me I was getting
touched I got thrown off my chair and I
was in we called it the computer room I
lived with my parents at the time and I
literally was thrown off the chair and
that's the same room where I was being
touched the treadmill was in there so
when I was on the treadmill I would feel
hands on me and these things were
happening and of course I went to my
psychic medium so you had a psychic too
of course I did you know I guess it's
like a doctor doesn't write his own
prescription that's right okay so you go
to the other sidekick yes I go to the
other psychic and I don't say a word
just see if she was going to pick up on
it and what was going on and she did and
she told me that I had a gift and I was
a medium and this is now the deceased
trying to communicate with me because I
also had um I would get psychic attacks
and dreams and I had a dream with this
deceased guy in it now long story short
he was connected to my daughter's father
um I wasn't with him anymore through his
girlfriend so this was somebody kind of
that was direct but indirect yeah so I
didn't know anything about this person
so indirect enough but Direct in the way
that I could get the message across to
my daughter's dad and so when I told him
about it he was like all right I'll go
ask if this is and I'm like this guy
died in a car accident he has blonde
hair he's young around 17. you know just
the whole description whatever I
received is what I gave he comes back a
week later to see my daughter and he's
like Jen I don't know what that was I
asked
um you know so and so about it and
that's her friend's brother he just died
that way that's what he looks like the
whole thing and I'm like whoa and so
that in conjunction with the other
things that were starting to happen to
me that's when I you know what brought
me to the medium and she told me I have
a gift they're trying to communicate
with me and I need to help people with
that here's a card
um a woman that when I referenced the
Divination group that I was in
she leaves this divination group you
need to go there and
um grow
you know grow your gift
um you know I I say it's not psychic
University but it was a divination class
where you're with like-minded people who
was doing Crystal readings Aura
um the whole kitten caboodle right and
um this you might find interesting this
woman literally the whole thing is
witchcraft
the crystal ball yeah and she was like
the cutest little woman and it was in
her house and she was so sweet and nice
and she had us all stand together like a
Kumbaya moment right and we're all
standing in a circle and she decides to
say the Lord's Prayer or as you would
know the Our father because after all
that's the most powerful prayer
protection she told us right before
she's about to practice divination wow I
mean but this is the deception Michael
that people really do need to know like
how deceptive it is because they're
going to use God words and
um even prayers and that's another way
to suck you into something that is so
demonic that's all new age right New Age
uses some real religious language and
then jumbles it up with all sorts of yes
demonic stuff yes uh which is you know
it says it in the Bible that you know
Lucifer can come Satan can come as an
angel of Light yes that's right so okay
you're you're doing this you're going to
psychic University you're you're
progressing in your training to be a
psychic
two questions one
does it pay very well yes yes and I
thought I was the nice guy which at the
time you know I mean I am the nice guy
but I didn't want people I wanted to be
able to reach all people so I wasn't
gonna charge with some of the other
psychics I mean you're talking hundreds
of dollars for a reading so I was not as
many hundreds of dollars but I was a
couple hundred dollars or so of reading
not in the beginning I started very
little and then I just built up and I I
then LED my own divination classes
and you're getting and let me tell you
something it's addictive that's the
whole thing it's addictive my clients
never left me alone I mean and my whole
business was Word of Mouth that was
because of the accuracy I shouldn't be
quoting it but you know what I mean
that's insightful because
I don't I'm not saying that all
psychological therapy is is bad I think
a lot of it is maybe there's a
comparison to be made here between that
and the psychics but the way I know
there's a bad psychologist is when when
someone goes to him for 30 years yeah
and someone says oh I've been to my
psychology I say well I guess it didn't
work yeah or or same thing with
Pharmaceuticals yeah I'm not against all
drugs right but the drug needs to work
needs to cure you it needs to help fix
your problem right if if you just keep
taking the drug and your problem doesn't
get better maybe your problem gets worse
you're addicted yeah well that's that's
not medicine yeah that's right that's a
drug addiction right and so of course
if the psychic came in and fixed your
problem
well
I guess that wouldn't that person
wouldn't be a psychic and it wouldn't
and the power is the control of the
psychic experience wouldn't be who they
are either well you hit the nail on the
head it's a hamster wheel
but that's what it is but they're
getting a taste of something that
fulfills them for 50 minutes yeah and
then because it's not what they're
really needing right they're looking for
peace they're looking for Joy they're
looking for answers they're looking for
wisdom they're looking for knowledge but
they're going to the wrong team for that
they're going to the Demonic side of
this not to God so everything that
they're looking for the devil will
promise you but he can't really deliver
right so you're on that hamster wheel
and then you get and and it escalates
Michael like you start with the tarot
cards even my own life but then it goes
to numerology astrology psychic
mediumship
um I had my Palms read three million
times I even did some witchcraft spells
with a couple of friends it wasn't
really my particular uh you know
expertise correct Forte right but I did
what
what kind of spells it was like one of
my friends she was like oh let's do this
money spell like really
like just to get more money just to get
more money yeah isn't it interesting
that how that always goes with it when
you think about anything demonic like it
goes with all like the greed The Pride
it's a really base kind of things yeah
you have to like put the and then you
have to cleanse things crystals I did
chakra balancing
yeah I only hear about this from my
white liberal lady friends the chakras
whatever what is that yeah well chakra
is in Sanskrit it means wheels so it's a
part of a the Hindu yeah
um belief system that they believe you
have something like 144 chakras but the
seven Prime area from your the top of
your head to the base of your spine so
this wheel represents energy like it's a
wheel of energy and when it's moving
around the right way and when it's open
then you would have
um ideal physical health emotional
health and psychic health and spiritual
health right so like the third eye
you've probably heard of that before the
third eye
um the Kundalini Spirit Kundalini Spirit
now that's part of the chakra too
because it's in the shape of a serpent
from the top of your head down right and
people claim to have this Kundalini
experience when it's unraveling and it's
like this not to say cathartic I'm gonna
it's not cathartic it's a little bit
more exciting than that
that's the family show you know that
part out or if you want but um that's
elusive enough it drives people
um crazy it but it will also drive you
crazy and that's when you see people
being knocked down being knocked over
out of order out of control and you know
that's demonic because you know the
fruit of the spirit is self-control
right right you know so so what I'm
trying to say is that all these new age
practices always intermingle and lead to
the next thing right they're not
compartmentalized and they always
promise that they're going to give you
all sorts of health and really frankly
when you want to look really good yeah
you've got to check out gen yourself
genucel sold out of their Dark Spot
Corrector they have been begging over
here around the daily wire and all of
you begging for a restock well it's here
make sure you get the genius elf Dark
Spot Corrector and all of the other
Essentials that Jenny cell has I really
love this company and I love the founder
the founder is a Coptic Christian from
Egypt who left Egypt came over here here
for the American dream and right now you
can get a terrific product from a
terrific company go to genucel.com
Knowles YT that is the letter y letter T
get all of these summer Essentials get
the Dark Spot Corrector get 70 off right
now on geniusell's most popular package
but you've got to do it go to
geniusell.com Knowles kwles y t letter y
letter T and you will get a mystery gift
included with every order but I'm not
going to tell you what that is now and
you're not a psychic so you don't know
what it is either go to genyourself.com
Knowles y t
thank you for the opportunity of that
not totally seamless transition
so you're engaged in all of these weird
practices does it ever Dawn on you that
this is a bit odd like crystal balls and
stuff
it um
the no it didn't seem odd it just seemed
um it seemed when I like I said when I
saw the scary things I had sleep
paralysis that was frightening really
frightening I wouldn't have known that's
what it was at the time I had it once
did you and it's spooky sleep paralysis
yes it is because you can't you're
you're totally awake but you can't move
and I heard I don't know I heard some
scary thing I don't remember exactly did
you see a demon I didn't see a demon but
I heard what sounded kind of demonic and
I didn't heard from one yeah it really
freaked me out and so I woke up I said
what the hell was that you know and you
know don't forget I'm at this point I
was reverting back to the church so I'm
coming out of atheism I'm
but at that point I would say I'm a
Christian you know and I so I so I
believed in all this stuff and I said
what you know what what did I just hear
a demon or something and uh Googled it
and discovered this phenomenon called
sleep paralysis so what did you
I was like like you you know you're wide
awake but I saw the demon standing right
in front of my bed and he manifested as
a black shadowy figure which you may
hear a lot because they manifest that
way a lot kind of like the Grim Reaper
without the without a sickle yeah yeah
and just stand staring at me and it was
just like a
like this and
um and then he's gone
and I was at that I was that that was
troubling that was troubling but because
I still believed that I had the power to
um light the sage you know light the
candles do the I could just this could
pass me by that was just an aspect of it
and maybe I need to do something a
little bit more maybe I need to get more
crystals maybe you keep going to the
problem for the solution in the new age
right right of course the other thing
I've heard this is the related question
two does it pay is I've heard that
sometimes government agencies will
enlist psychic mediums Is that real
um I believe it is because I saw
somebody on Tick Tock I'm a Tic Tac
Creator yeah and um I saw somebody on
Tick Tock that
um he's a medium and he they they
enlisted him and he he was I think he
had had a government job in the past to
find a missing boy
the missing boy thank God was found and
is alive and the medium provided some
information for them and uh and and I
think this is great to bring it up
because
his information was accurate and led to
finding the missing boy but here's the
thing demons saw the the boy right he
they knew where he was so so this guy is
so
um connected if you will to the Demonic
they're feeding him information left and
right why not
and so there's a good end that comes out
of that they find this missing boy well
but couldn't that good end have been had
through God right right yeah look I
don't like what's the alternative right
I don't think that uh
good ends justify immoral means yes you
know I think that that very notion has
gotten us into a whole lot of trouble
I'm I believe in all this stuff I think
it's all real I think that the Bible
doesn't say don't consult mediums and
necromancers not because it's all fake
and silly but because it is real and bad
and we shouldn't do it you know yes but
for people who don't believe that this
stuff happens
what do you say to them what if for the
people who say oh this lady was just
crazy and having all sorts of kooky
experiences and I'm glad she's normal
now you can't even you you can't get
away with that one I and I and trust me
I have to go into this a lot with what I
do
um just being out there and I start with
my testimony I'll tell people my
testimony and I'll explain I'll sit
there and say listen if you and I just
met today and I I would have given you a
reading I don't have to well you you're
they would say well you probably Googled
or whatever okay so take back that
example just your your um someone
without a Wiki page though yeah there
you go somebody without that not that I
even knew how to work technology and
also I don't think we even had certain
things when I was doing it but anyway I
digress I would say listen I sat before
strangers and was able to get
information about them I never met them
and like I said even in random places I
would just go out and I just started
hearing chatter about people and that
was tough because then I had to decide
am I going to go up to this person and
ask my if I can give them this
information or am I not going to do that
I mean these are perfect strangers would
you go up to them sometimes oh yeah you
just walk up to someone say hey by the
way you know you're I'm a psychic I get
information and I just heard something
about you is it okay to give you and of
course everybody's like yes
they want it they want the information
so I just try to do it from a relatable
way Michael like if someone says oh no
this is all crazy say listen
I get why you think that way and you and
please don't insult people with mental
illness because it's not mental illness
you know what I mean I tell them like
you can't have a controlled like sit
there like okay here's my client I have
their name and number that's it and then
boom I hear about your grandma
you know that's not mental illness
that's um information being given to me
about you you know you know why I
believe the psychics are often real is
I I was maybe 22 or 23. I was an actor
in my wayward youth professional actor
that's not a movie set and made friends
with this gal and we were chatting and
she was Italian we were talking about
Dante so I don't know much about that so
I'm I love Dante so I'm talking about
Dante in this poem this thing reminded
me of this poem and I'm reciting these
poems okay bye see you later
as it didn't say her for quite some time
then I was going in to an audition
and I see this guy I said oh hey how's
it going I haven't seen you while she
goes I can't believe I'm seeing you I
just went to my psychic she goes I just
went to my psychic and I sit down I've
gone to the psychic for a long time and
the first thing she says to me she says
who's Dante huh and this really freaked
me out and I was at the time coming out
of my atheism reverting to the church
and
the thing that freaked me out about it
is not that the psychic knew that we
talked about Dante or whatever because
that's a very odd thing to bring up
it's that psychics were real that's what
freaked me out right I said oh I guess
there's more in Heaven and Earth than is
dreamed of in our philosophy Horatio
it was a psychic on Long Island actually
really maybe you knew her we'll have to
talk about that after when we're not on
camera right probably did we were a very
close Circle
we read each other
a lot of us mediums we a lot of us came
from the same divination group not that
it was at all different times and
um kind of like a hub Long Island is
loaded with psychics I don't know if
it's all water or what I'm like I
remember I grew up in Westchester and I
I it was just you know just north of the
city and I
used to hear about these things that
there was occult activity and some of
some of the towns in Westchester turns
around me and I kind of wrote it off I
said oh whatever that's kind of nonsense
and I don't know and now in my old age I
go back and I think about these things
and I hear more people say that there is
a lot of this activity around New York
there is I I honestly I don't know it's
it's
um
so accepted it's so accepted I mean
you're seeing a lot of metaphysical
stores popping up on I mean in Long on
Long Island I mean queens and Manhattan
every other every half block yeah
there's a there's a palm reader there's
a you know
um but Long Island now you're seeing
full on
um psychics with similar you know
pictures on their on their storefronts
and metaphysical shops with the crystals
and everything I mean there's one right
by my church it's it's crazy it really
is but we live in a culture now that is
I hate to say it but so Godless like God
is being pushed out and less of God
means more of you and more of the
Demonic and then
um you know wanting uh like I said
before wanting that knowledge wanting
right wanting power so what
I kind of lived through it so I maybe I
should ask myself this question but why
we live in an age where people say you
believe in god wow how stupid are you
you're so backwards and dumb you're
knuckle dragging troglodyte but then all
the really fancy people who say that
believe in all this crap the pardon my
French like the the Reiki and the
crystals and the psychics and everything
and they'll go they'll have psychics
they'll go to Spirit cooking dinners at
the highest echelons of American power
and and
I think hold on you think that I'm
gullible for believing
a
religion that took over the entire world
with 500 eyewitnesses to the
resurrection and an unbroken line going
back to the apostles into our Lord
himself and where I just like go to
church on Sunday night like a normal
person right and you think I'm a nut for
doing that but you're going out and you
still think you're talking to dead
people and you're playing around with
crystals and weird witch ladies like
my question is how
how can you be that gullible to fall for
all that stuff
but then think you're you're too
scientistic and empirical and serious to
believe in God please
like will you already
wear something Supernatural so I would I
would you know I would say you already
know there's a spiritual realm you're
not completely ignorant to the fact of
um Spirit the spiritual realm you're
you're diving in there with the yoga
with the well some well let's be honest
too some of it is just they're so
completely deceived because they believe
that yoga is just breathing and
stretching they believe that Reiki is
just uh healing modality and the answer
to all their problems like anxiety and
all that stuff but the other side of it
when you think about it the part that
they do know and they're they're they're
wanting the spiritism part of it they
find it very intriguing the Paranormal
um they are subscribing to the spiritual
realm but they're not subscribing to an
authority so they're still it's like a
baby God yeah theology right they're
they're their own authority yes yeah
yeah right individualism yes yeah a
friend said to me recently the culture's
idea of the Holy Trinity is me myself
and I yeah is isn't it true wow and it's
something
you know we mock especially the atheists
on the left tends to be there more on
the left
they say oh you you guys you're pushing
your radical subjective individualism
but the right does that too I mean the
right also has exalted individualism and
relativism and the idea that you have
some right to believe whatever you want
to do and do whatever you want to do and
that's your freedom or something it's
completely antithetical to the classical
and Christian conception of freedom but
it is the liberal conception of freedom
I mean there's a friend of mine once
made a very persuasive argument that the
devil in Milton's Paradise Lost is a
classical liberal that's what Milton is
describing I think there's quite a lot
to that
says question of authority is really
interesting like when when someone says
well I'm spiritual but not religious or
you know I don't like organized religion
or I don't like you know someone making
exclusive religious claims I just want
to do my own thing right it's like
saying
it's like saying I'm really interested
in myself I grant that there is this
whole realm I just don't care what God
says about it right it's so right that's
so true that's what spirituality is
that's what that's when people call
themselves spiritual that's exactly what
that is I think even John MacArthur
mentioned that with uh in his Ben
Shapiro
um interview he said spirituality is you
not subscribing to any Authority you
make the rules you get to decide what's
good and what's bad and um I I wonder
what do they think really happens when
you die though you know what I mean
right like what do you think really
happens well I guess if you can speak to
the dead through the mediums then you
believe you're going to the other side
and it's just fine and that's what's
said Michael that's actually that you
know that's what breaks my heart because
you and I both know that we're Sinners
that need a savior you know and that's
through Christ that we because we do go
on I mean this isn't the this isn't the
last stop you know it's like a and it's
a blip on the radar yeah and that's why
I'm so yes exactly and that's why I'm so
passionate about exposing it so when you
were a psychic professionally did you
help people
no you didn't no
can I explain that yeah please because
people think that the psychic is helping
I believed I was helping people for
those moments that they were connecting
through their grief they were Grievous
they're lonely even the people that were
just looking for the job or you know
needing guidance
um or Insight
um it's not helpful because you're
including them in a demonic practice
you're you're deceived and you're
helping to deceive them the devil's
using he used me as a pawn and that's
what he uses psychics as a porn to do
his dirty work and then once that person
has come for the reading now they've
opened the Demonic door and then you
want to talk about some scary business
demonic oppression possession is rare I
know that's a whole big thing but it's a
long interview with a Exorcist and
there's yeah there's a distinction here
between yes demonic possession vexation
oppression Temptation was just the most
common one of us but that is a
consequence that's guaranteed once you
open the door to the demand it's
guaranteed however it's gonna I always
say that the the devil attacks the
Demonic attacks are personal
just like Jesus died for us personally
we have a personal faith with him those
demonic attacks are personal because
what's going to get to me is going to be
different than what gets to you right so
whether it's anxiety confusion the sleep
paralysis the nightmares
um doubts
um things start going wrong in your life
because listen the devil doesn't care
about you
who care about you hates God and he
hates man he's willing to give you a
little bit of what you want for now
and let you pay the price let you pay
the consequences of it
so it's um really a very dangerous thing
so you're not helping anybody when
you're a psychic at all so when when did
you come out of it did was it a you know
Saul on the road to Damascus come to
Jesus moment or was it a
you're kind of starting to recognize
some things off here I was it was the it
was the end of my 36th year so I was
late in the game already and um
let me tell you something the Demonic
oppression on me in that moment was
about to cause a destruction like no
other in that moment I'm not even going
to call it the end of myself moment it
was worse than that and I cried out to
Jesus Christ and I know now that's
really the Holy Spirit who even was able
to nudge my heart to draw me to do that
and I just cried out I cried out his
name and I had a piece that came over me
all of a sudden and of course like
anybody might say well you don't know
what that piece was whatever no I knew
that was Jesus but so no it was not a
pull it was not a soul pull conversion
because this took a little bit of time I
hadn't heard the gospel I hadn't read
the Bible I just yeah no her no I mean
I know people say well what do you mean
you went to church I mean I was
culturally Catholic that's how I was
raised so you know we were the lasagna
we would Christmas because the Christmas
Eve maybe definitely Christmas Day
Sometimes some Christmases not every
um so no I really that's why I said I
didn't know that I was a sinner that
needed a savior I didn't know that I had
broken God's will you know I didn't know
any of that yeah so I cry out to Jesus
he shows up and I don't know what any of
this means but I knew that I didn't want
to be a psychic anymore but I didn't
know why I had no idea why so I'm like
okay what do I do now so I start going
reading books from the library just
about experiences so I further got
deceived
um
I read some really sketch books they
were not good they were not good and so
I became what I call spiritually
vulnerable
for a period of time I stopped doing
readings but then I went back to it
because it was all it was all I knew it
was I I wasn't convinced yet that it was
bad I didn't know why I didn't want to
do it anymore and I just changed the way
I spoke in the beginning I was like
listen you know um there's a God and
God's in control and then I go into the
reading so
um
but God didn't give up on me when I was
I turned 37 a friend came over from the
Divination group we had become very good
friends I read her family her friends
she comes over for dinner and little did
I know this woman had been saved in the
since the last time I had seen her so
she starts telling me about this church
and about Jesus and I'm like nah I'm
good you go to your church I'm like what
I passed I passed on the church I passed
on the whole thing I said no and then a
month later I woke up on a Sunday and I
said I want to go with you to that
church today I don't know why
but I want to go and that was the day
that Jesus really reached me he reached
me I'm singing the song Jesus saved me
and I flashed back now this was 10
months later
from that first moment that I cried out
to him
always with the hands so um I'm Italian
yeah that's so yeah this is well it's
just uh well useless because you know
yeah
um
yeah and I'm singing and Jesus saved me
and I flashed back to that moment and it
was like him giving me that confirmation
and the Holy Spirit just came into my
heart and I heard the gospel and
um I was set free it was me I just
started crying in that church I wonder
if it's easier
for
people to convert from
occultism than it is from atheism or the
Opera you know because at least you knew
that like spirit is real you didn't
think we're just bags of meat you know
you're kind of under and you knew and
you'd had pretty vivid experiences of
this so
I don't know I don't know or
but there's a deception that goes along
with that too that maybe is harder to
break out of
so you you you come out of it you you
now say okay that stuff's bad I believe
in our Lord and you know want to be
saved
but you just lost your job it's not only
that you lost your fake religion you
lost your job yes I'm not going to say
there wasn't a little anxiety there yeah
and I was the breadwinner at the time
and
um but I I couldn't just well two things
one the gravity of my salvation Michael
when I realized what Jesus Set Me Free
from because the first thing the Holy
Spirit did was lead me to the word of
God I mean I'm talking 15 minutes later
after that church service I'm home now
I'm Googling what does the Bible say
about psychic mediums and the list comes
up and I'm like wow shoot I should have
Googled this earlier
and Deuteronomy 18 10 to 12 which really
gives us the practices that fall under
Witchcraft and the word medium was there
and I was like God's talking to me
that's me I wow I have to quit my job I
just have to do it Jesus Set Me Free if
I had died as a psychic medium you know
where I was going it was not to be with
the Lord Jesus so he gave me that
opportunity he gave me a chance to be
saved and have eternal life Lord Jesus
wherever you lead me I'm going and I'm
getting rid of whatever I have to get
rid of and I did a full repentance I
mean I I quit my job
I met with the pastor of that church and
he was cool he was like look I don't pay
your bills he's like but I'd be a bad
pastor if I told you to continue you
know being a psychic
and I'm like no I already made the
decision I can't do it it's clearly
against God I mean he's clear from the
beginning of the word to the end of it
and I know that's not because he's an
angry grandpa he's not trying to be a
buzz kill it's because it's to protect
us because it's demonic do you miss it
ever never you don't no you don't miss
the feeling of I had this power or this
special thing the secret knowledge no I
don't I don't miss doing anything for
the devil I couldn't I love the Lord
Michael so it's not a temptation but in
in that a guy could uh he could be a
crack addict right and recognize okay
this is terrible for me and uh and maybe
let's say his his uh
giving it up is part of a religious
conversion so it's really all grounded
in God and but he'll still if there's
crack on the table you know he might
still be tempted by it right or you
could or with uh lust or I don't know or
like five cupcakes on the table it would
be the same thing if your sin is
gluttony you don't feel that pull no and
I wonder if it's because if you think
about it you can't drink from the cup of
the Lord and the cup of demons right so
you can't serve God and the devil at the
same time if you have a sin like that
um an addiction rather a bondage a chain
like drugs or food I I it's a sin but
it's not directly serving the devil do
you know what I mean by that I mean it's
not it's not so direct whereas like you
know
when you're a psychic medium you're I
guess the sin there would be Pride yeah
which is the queen of all Vice and
you're like literally you're literally
communicating with demons you're like hi
you know it's like it's hard to just
dabble in that one yeah you know like if
you're a glutton and you eat the cupcake
it's like okay oh I'm sorry Lord I need
I need your help with this but if you're
making a choice to talk to a demon I
mean it's a little more clear and
extreme yeah that's a good point so you
you've come out of it now and I suppose
also back when you were a medium you
could say well I can bring you this kind
of hope and that I'll talk to your dead
uncle or something but now you can say
look I don't I'm not really
a part I'm not special exactly but I can
bring you a real hope which is grounded
in history and the Incarnation and the
resurrection the crucifixion the
resurrection
which is just called evangelism that's
what that's what all Christians are
called to do it's a little more grounded
I guess because the thing that's the
thing that's really striking about you
and if I didn't already believe that the
psychic stuff is real I I would probably
believe it talking to you because you
seem normal thank you
and it's I've noticed this on this
series we've disproportionately even if
we didn't start out this way we end up
talking about spiritual topics and
talking to you you're talking to my
Exorcist friend mother rehill the thing
that strikes you when you talk to
exorcists is how not weird they are
right they it's they sound like plumbers
when they talk about their job wow and I
find this even if I get a little bit I
don't know a little spooked I feel like
there's something a little off and I
just say a prayer I often I'll say the
same Michael prayer you know which was
uh Pope Leo the 13th wrote it
um in a in a Flash in a flash of
inspiration because he seemed to believe
that the occult was really On The Rise
and the prayer is say Michael Archangel
tennis and Battle Bear defense against
the wickedness and snares of the devil
may God rebuke him we humbly pray and do
thou Prince of the Heavenly Host by the
power of God thrust into hell Satan in
all the evil spirits who prowled about
the world seeking the ruin of Souls and
it's a really it encapsulates a lot of
what we're talking about with spiritual
warfare and but I just say it and then I
think I don't know to me I think of the
Demons like they're bugs like they're
cockroach I don't like them I don't want
to see them I don't I'm not that scared
of them but I'm not in you know I'm not
I'm still a little bit scared like I
don't want I don't want him around me
you know and and there's something
really matter of fact about that
um I'm I appreciate what you said first
of all thank you that you feel uh that
I'm relatable and I think that's what
you're trying to say yes yeah um you
don't seem kooky you know it seemed
weird I'm literally like I go on my Tick
Tock live with a cup of coffee and
um you know uh and and I want to be
relatable and share my experiences so
that people do understand how real it is
and the danger of it and it is the devil
is prowling around seeking to whom he
may devour I mean he is I mean the Bible
tells us that but it's true this is a
real and present danger and um I don't
mean to go off you know Veer off a
little bit but
um you know especially with the
spiritual blindness that we're seeing
um today in all worlds you know this
Godless world and as God is you know
shoved over here you know the devil is
being um front and center you know you
can see it in the culture but um uh yeah
it's not just that God is being shoved
to the side by people who are or you
know actively doing the work of demons
who are consciously doing it
it's so much more subtle and and
sad yeah the separation of church and
state yeah this is something that our
founding fathers did not establish the
line comes from one letter from Thomas
Jefferson who was one of the bigger Libs
among the founding fathers but they were
all John Adams said the country's going
to be grounded in Christian morality
John Jay said thank goodness it's a
Christian Nation you know we've got one
nation under God in our currency it's in
the national anthem you know
America understood itself as a Christian
Nation for most of our history until the
middle of the 20th century we start with
this idea we're liberal democracy we
need a separation of church and state
well okay if you're saying we're going
to banish God from a Public Square
good luck right let's see how that works
out for you it hasn't worked out very
well in my experience right exactly
exactly and um that is I think what's
making it so prevalent today the uh
witchcraft if I may it's uh yeah because
you're not seeing
you're not seeing um
the Lord front and center like I said
you're not so it just hey okay so here
you go I mean is the nation under God's
judgment I think I was watching well I
was watching I'm pretty sure John
McArthur said that in one of his sermons
um during the time of the c word
um you know that the unutterable
five-letter c word I didn't say it
nobody heard me didn't say a thing
um but being under God's judgment I mean
it's like hey you know okay you want to
live this way you want to do things
without me go for it you know and like
you said how do you like it now how's it
going right for you you know um right
you know
there's the
psychic aspect to all of this but you
mentioned something at the top
which is there are sometimes physical
manifestations
right of this occult stuff that you've
experienced and I think that's a level
where some people will say
okay now I really don't believe I don't
believe that someone could be thrown out
of a chair I don't believe that lights
could flicker on and off
without a natural explanation
but you've seen it I've seen it and I
and I've I still see it from time to
time so let me explain that
um as a Christian
uh we are not exempt from demonic
oppression right so we can go through uh
spiritual attack and I've gone through
some spiritual attacks
um
even you know fairly recently the
differences for me of course then I know
to call upon the name of Jesus and you
know put on the armor of God and and
pray and read the Bible more and do all
that kind of stuff but um I've had sleep
paralysis I've had a I had a psychic
attack a couple months ago
um what's that like so a psychic attack
this will happen in one day I actually
so I had a dream in the morning now the
thing with the dreaming is that it's not
that the devil is you know getting into
your mind that's not what he's doing
he's not slipping into your brain
um that would be like a possession
rather I say that you're kind of in like
in between states and whenever you're in
like a vulnerable state I there you can
be attacked okay You're vulnerable your
guard is enough do you know what I mean
no I I do in in that that
I'm much less prone to Vice and a little
bit better at practicing virtue most of
the time
unless I'm really overworked or really
tired or really stressed or really those
are the moments when I I feel I'm more
I'll lose my temper or something when
I'm in my daily life I I'm a lot better
at it but there are these moments when
You Know You're vulnerable yeah
definitely and
um so that happened uh I believe that's
the state that you're in sometimes in
these dream states
um or you're half awake half asleep
whatever so I had this dream and the
dream was the dream you know I was with
my aunt and uncle and then I was then my
cousin popped in the dream
um and she's like hey I want you to come
with me this weekend
um on a cruise to Aruba or whatever I'm
like you know I don't like boats I'm not
going on this cruise but I'm fine leave
it alone I didn't even think about the
dream and I had been thinking about
seeing my aunt and uncle so I'm like
okay that's just you know day residue
you know I was thinking about seeing
them
later that day I saw a demon manifested
on my front porch and it was kind of a
gray figure and here's the thing
it's
um
uh not how we are third dimensional you
know how we're solid like that you can
see a figure but it's Misty so it's not
like and I wouldn't call it a ghost I'd
call it a demon and later that night I
was talking to my cousin on the phone my
her brother and he said oh Jen you you
know you really should come I said yeah
I had the dream I I think it's because
I'm thinking about it or whatever and he
said no you really should come
um but not this weekend because
um Angela is going on a cruise to Aruba
or a trip to Aruba or whatever and I'm
like oh
no no why did I and I know that might
sound so mundane
um but it's something I had no idea
about and that was I mean that was like
right there and I saw the demon that day
that's a psychic no no because
for a drug addict if he gets a
Temptation in a dream he's thinking
about drugs for uh you know a guy who
deals with lust he has a Temptation and
a dream it's going to be a chick in a
bikini for uh
for a former psychic medium who has a
Temptation and a dream what's it going
to be I assume it's going to be a
Temptation right toward psychic readings
which is what happened
yeah I don't know well I don't know if I
would have called it a Temptation though
I I was you it literally just got one I
was yeah it was just it but it made
sense because the whole Singh was a
demonic attack I've I've also had
um where I was up in the middle of the
night and I heard a demon but it sounded
like my dad's voice talking to me and I
know that sounds I know I'm really
putting myself out there because I
probably sound crazy yeah I believe all
this stuff I mean I believe people can
be deceived too but I believe all this
stuff is possible yeah like at this
point though you know what it is I have
good discernment I can tell when
something is demonic and when something
is not and I don't think there's a demon
behind every corner yeah I mean I'm not
that person like you know but um when I
see it and I hear it I know it because I
lived it for years I can tell the
difference
if I get so serious about it I can tell
the difference I'm not a crazy person no
offense to anybody who is
um but that's not what this is there is
a demonic
um War if there's a demonic battle
there's a demonic attack we know that
Ephesians 6 12 tells us we don't wrestle
against flesh and blood right we wrestle
against the the principalities the
cosmic powers and the Darkness in the
Heavenly places guys that's it guys I'm
like I'm a tick tock Michael that is a
rank of demons that's what's out there
that's what's good it's an invisible
battle but it is being fought and we are
part of it when you talk about the gray
shadowy figure I'm reminded
Aleister Crowley oh the infamous
occultist and satanistan he did a sketch
once
of a demon he had this vision of a demon
and he just sketched at the demon and
the demon looked his vision of a demon
looked like what we would call aliens
okay like little gray Little Green Men
you know with big eyes and a big head
and it just looked like out of any any
alien movie was and but also it was dark
and shadowy and gray and kind of like
what you're describing wow interesting I
never saw any of his work thank God I
don't recommend it but it is spooky in
that you hear about all of these now
paranormal UFO type things
I think the UFO stuff is nonsense but or
I think the notion of extraterrestrial
aliens is nonsense but totally agree you
do so you know
so is that demons I think or is it just
people
I think that if you're somebody that you
see something yourself like you you see
something manifest that could possibly
be a demon and I don't mean like you're
seeing a spaceship or something and
you're seeing a little guy come out now
I mean really like you're seeing um
flickering lights or something like that
um when you're outside or whatever I
mean I'm really stretching this
um but I think otherwise I think it's
mostly nonsense that's what I think the
alien people are just kind of people you
can imagine things people hallucinate
and I love how that's so acceptable too
but God no not so much nothing really
it's a great place it's happening well I
always say aliens it's just Angels and
Demons for liberals for materialists who
refuse to believe in spiritual things so
they say oh it's got to be I believe in
every single religious or mythical story
I've ever heard in history but they've
got to have like green flesh right as
long as they have green flash and
spaceships it's totally fine uh
but this this continues to happen to you
when I reverted from atheism to the
church uh
it was the most intense
bizarre period of
vexation Temptation in my whole life and
I've heard this from a lot of people
though that it's it's
at that moment when you might be making
a change in pursuing a better path
that's when all the guns are going to be
aimed at you yes absolutely and actually
and a lot of people ask me this when I
was set free and I quit my job I still
as a psychic medium I started counseling
with the pastor
um a pastor at that church that I
started going to and
um so how it worked was there were three
pastors senior pastor was away one week
and so this pastor the one that was
counseling me he was saying the sermon I
was so excited to get into church I'm
only like a few weeks in I'm a baby
Christian I'm there in church so excited
and my pastor who was counseling me
Pastor Jonathan he comes up there to say
the sermon I don't know that they you
know take turns like I don't know how
this works right and he starts saying
the sermon Michael everything I mean I
started getting information about him
psychically and I thought you know I
didn't know the deal I didn't know about
the spiritual battle I thought once I
repented I was just so good we're done
bye see you later well you know no I was
attacked uh spiritually psychically
sitting there information about Pastor
Jonathan I really felt like I was
freaking out I felt like why is this
happening to me I felt scared was I
doing something wrong and um
I met with him that Tuesday like I
always would and I was hesitant to tell
him because I thought like am I like a
bad Christian like what you know
and I thank God that I really was driven
by the Holy Spirit to tell him and not
be isolated with that another scheme of
the devil I'm sure and I told him and he
said well you can tell me what was said
we won't give the demon any Glory but
you can just tell me what we said I
repeated I told him what information I
got he said I'm not gonna lie that hit a
nerve
he said I'm not gonna lie to you he's
like um but you know
um how the devil does things is always
like what you said in the beginning you
know he there's going to be some truth
with the lies and how he twists things
but there's always going to be some
something there but what is he giving
you information like you know Jonathan
just baked a pie for the Widow across
the street or is he saying No this guy
did this sin and he's a really bad guy
no it was something about his life when
he was a child
and particular relationships that he had
and the feelings he had about those
relationships
I know this guy like what at this point
I don't know four weeks he's counseling
me I'm not interviewing him about his
family I know nothing about his family
I'm just going there to listen to the
sermon that's all I'm doing right and I
got that information and it was really
personal
and that's why I'm sure it hit the nerve
that it did for him
um but at least then thank God I gave
him that and we were able to talk about
it because then he was able to help me
with the power of prayer and
um you know and and what to do applying
those biblical principles when you're
being attacked so
this notion that the psychics when
they're hearing from demons that it's
truth that you can point to that'll
spook people out because you say when
there were three you know this happened
with falsehood yeah
what's the percentage I mean how
how much deception is there and how much
truth is there okay well anything that
they report that has already happened
they can report that that's going to be
true of course that's going to be 100
accurate
in order to prove to the person that's
right now everything else that they say
because now you're hanging on to every
word that comes out of their mouth now
right because they were able to tell you
what you did last week they were able to
tell you your mom and dad and things
like Dante and and this that and the
other right now you're like oh okay I
wonder what else they're gonna say so
anything that's a prediction
is already a lie even if they end up
coming true Michael and I'll tell you
why because they don't know everything
only God does only God does right but
can they are they good guessers
absolutely do they get their hands in it
by manipulating by almost creating the
atmosphere the climate for you to do you
know kind of like a self-fulfilling
uh prophecy you know what I mean so like
you almost end up doing the thing like
the the girl with the Ouija board right
the girl who you know if she's
especially the way she died it's not so
much a prediction as a you know a push
right a push yeah yeah but it's not
everything anything else I give this
analogy right let's say I mean you know
you're married
um you know what your wife does Monday
to Friday I'm sure
um she does this for 364 days of the
year on the 365th you're going to be
able to make a prediction let's say it's
fresh pasta night yeah there you go
that's uh hopefully that's a push-up
I'll say I'd like that
um but you're gonna have you're going to
make a prediction if I asked you to you
would say well at 6am she's going to do
this at 7am but you're not God right so
you don't know for sure yeah something
different can happen that day
but you've seen you've not that you're
trying to study her like a creepy Demon
Lord willing Michael but you're but
you're too oblivious for that it's not
that I'm too virtuous but I'm certainly
too oblivious you didn't have noticed
that my hair got cut no I noticed were
you talking
but you've seen like you've what like
you know you know this is somebody you
know like you you can give better than
anybody else a good percentage of what
she's going to do on a Monday night you
know that you're married to someone for
long enough you don't even you could
have a conversation just by looking at
each other you know exactly you know
what he's going to say and she's going
to say and that yeah yeah so if people
can do that Michael you take something
like demons a creature that is far more
intelligent sorry human beings but they
are far more intelligent and far more
powerful and older and older
there you go right right
I'm struck by what you're saying because
there's it seems like for everything
you're describing in the occult psychic
Realm there is a flip side in the
saintly realm so you know you're sitting
there and you're getting this weird
psychic attack looking at this guy
Pastor Jonathan
there there's a charism attested too by
the great science in history which is
the charism to read Souls and even
people have encountered these sorts of
some of these people today who can have
a
uncanny ability to just
read a soul I don't know I don't know
how else to say it and uh some of them
are in religious orders some of them are
in the laity but you know it's just like
I don't know I don't have that charism
but some people have it uh or you know
the prophets you know before
um before the Incarnation the prophets
had an ability in a way to tell the
future but also you know maybe the more
important thing about profits is they
see the truth in their own time you know
so the prophet's really telling the
truth more than he's predicting the
future though you will see that resonate
in the future
is it just a like a weird mirror image
is that no it's a deliberate counterfeit
it's a deliberate counterfeit the devil
is
um a copycat
you know there's really no other way to
say that he's a copycat and you are so
right I just spoke about this recently
with the new um article about Raven
Simone and on her podcast she was
talking about her psychic abilities oh
was she the girl from The Cosby Show
oh was she oh yeah that's right I keep
thinking of her from That's So Raven
right my daughter is 22. so she went
yeah and that's what killed me because
you think about that nostalgic feeling
towards some of these celebrities that
the youth has and then now they're
coming out and they're talking about
these things he's a psychic oh she has
um she's she's addressing her psychic
abilities that she's had for quite some
time and one thing she brings up is
Spirit guides and so when you're talking
about that I'm thinking about the
counterfeit and to me
um a spirit guide is a count it's a
demon first of all all psychics new
agers have Spirit guides
um like I said before to filter in and
out good and bad spirits um give you
psychic information about yourself
um lead you and guide you in wisdom and
Truth doesn't that sound a little bit
minus the psychic like the Holy Spirit
like to lead us like into truth and good
decisions and wisdom
um that's who the devil is though and
he's been doing this for ages he's a big
copycat even if you think of the Exodus
right when God Called Moses and with the
um with the staff and then Pharaoh
called in the sorcerers to come in right
and they're trying to and they do their
tricks too but seriously you know that's
the kind of the odd thing is they also
performed all sorts of weird a little
yeah they did but that's what what was
cool about and I hate to say it this way
but it is isn't God cool it was cool how
God showed how he was the only one who
got with the ten plagues because every
time because they had a God for denial
of God for fly is a God for where's your
God now yeah you know like right but but
that is
um he's a he's a trickster the Devil
he's a manipulator he's a deceiver he's
a liar and he's a copycat and like you
mentioned before
which is second Corinthians 11 14 and
15. Satan masquerades and that's what
people need to know Michael what all of
us need to know because we can all be
duped he masquerades as an angel of
Light and Angel is a messenger so you've
got to be so super Discerning when you
hear something that somebody is saying
or doing because again you're not
fighting against the flesh and blood but
what are they operating under what
Spirits are they operating under right
so if we if he's putting on a mask hey
I'm your mom or dad I'm coming through
in this reading no you're a demon
um we have to be so on guard yeah
there's this modern notion that in
pre-christian civilizations
all these people they had such weird
bizarre mythological systems you know
they'd worshiped Jupiter or they'd have
bacchanals or they would worship Apollo
or Athena or something or the Middle
Eastern worship the balls or whoever and
boy isn't that really kooky what does
that say about those people that they
would worship those gods that aren't
real but
in a way they are real right they're
demons like the traditional view the I
think the augustinian view and the view
that prevailed until recent modern times
are very stupid times that we're living
in is that no they're real and these
guys just worship demons and the demons
would kind of help them a little bit not
ultimately ultimately they'd really mess
them up but
they were real and the the worship that
these Pagan peoples past and present
would give to them
is real and there would be something
that would come out of that like a
psychic medium like uh I don't know any
manifesting like manifesting whatever
it's real and so now we're in this new
age we're told and I interviewed a guy
on this show not long ago who calls
himself a shaman
what struck me is he's very intelligent
guy obviously and he he would say some
things that were true and some things
that were coherent uh but mixed in with
a lot of things that are very much not
true or other things that just seem kind
of bizarre and he wouldn't call himself
a new Ager but he he would literally use
the language he said we're in a New Age
and and you know he was he was a new
Ager uh
I have friends and relatives who are
into the new age stuff it's it's
I think it's a lot more pervasive than
people are willing to admit yeah
do you think that though actually I'm
saying yeah but
oh I see what you yeah because I I would
say out of 10 people probably eight are
into it right that's what I mean yeah
but I wouldn't have said I would have
thought
like if you ask people hey are you a new
age or nine out of ten would say no but
even I'm certainly not a new Ager but
I'll say hey man stop harshing my vibes
and I'll say it somewhat ironically but
Vibes refers to vibrations right refers
to an actual New Age concept right and
we all do that kind of stuff
right don't we all just even in our our
equatorian language we didn't do that
yeah yeah we do and then hopefully we
realize and then we don't do it again
you know but um but you're absolutely
right those people won't say they're new
agers they'll just say they're spiritual
right wow right
you know it that's what they'll say
they'll say they're spiritual they're
just spiritual I've I've often mocked
the phrase I'm spiritual but not
religious but
maybe one ought to be harsher with that
phrase because
practically speaking it just is
synonymous with I practice New Age
occultism yeah
yeah because you're not even willing to
say like if you asked me I wouldn't if
you
I'm Christian
yeah I'm not just spiritual is there a
spiritual of course there's a spirit I
mean but that oh no I know who I
subscribe to I say I'm religious they
say are you spiritual I said I'm
religious because what's religion
religion is uh a habit that that
inclines the will to render to God it's
a virtue that inclines the will to to
render to God that which is owed to him
amen and I add on and say I have a
relationship with my Lord and Savior
Jesus Christ and how loving and and you
know you think about that I hate to say
Down to Earth but that Jesus wants to
have a relationship with us how how
amazing is that that God's not just some
you know Puppeteer and where you know
and you know dangling us around but that
we have a choice to come to him
willingly and he wants that he wants us
to come to him willingly on your point
of the cheap counterfeits yeah we've had
throughout the church
uh from the very beginning since Christ
walked the Earth
sacraments what is a Sacrament a
Sacrament is the meaning of the physical
and the metaphysical right so it's a
thing that we do
and that we receive that has a physical
component and a spiritual and
metaphysical meaning it's alive that's
really happening and so we you know you
think of Holy Communion or you think of
confession or you think of you know
baptism obviously baptism
well the new age the weird occult
psychic stuff they have pseudo
sacraments too the tarot cards the
readings the crystals the sage they it
but it's just a cheap knockoff for the
real the real uh
presence of the Living God
rituals they have rituals the new age
um you know I'm not Catholic so I you're
you're you know you're informing me of
things about you know but um uh but the
new age these practices are very
ritualistic and the fact that I even had
to look back like honestly I was just
the girl next door I wasn't like dressed
up in like scary looking clothes and
things like that all this to say that
looking back and realized I was
practicing witchcraft yeah wow I
couldn't even see it wow yeah the whole
thing even in that divination group even
when I did my owner when I did readings
I had a ritual light the candle light
the um the sage I used to get hired to
go into people's houses this is crazy
because so many people
um think this right
I used to get hired to go into people's
houses smudge the house and read like
Channel while I was smudging to see what
Souls were trapped in the house so you
would call that like haunted like a
haunted house right and you see these
shows now a lot of the shows right
they're going out with all their
paraphernalia like they're paranormal
like the little radio the lights on
their head and they're going in there
because they're believing that demons
um rather I'm sorry the people they
don't I don't know if any of them call
them demons but
um that there's activity
um Vanessa Hutchins was at like a
cemetery
um
Cemetery with Gigi Hadid and they're
they're there
um hey how are you I'm Vanessa Hutchins
who are you and what
and
anyway that was a whole long thing it's
so striking because I didn't even notice
this right I didn't even see half the
thing I see them and it doesn't even
register how
weird it is and especially now we look
back at history and people always say oh
there's awful people in the past I would
have been so much better had I been
around them and one of the
moments that keeps cropping up is Salem
Witch Trials which were a bit odd and it
was these kind of
more eccentric Puritans who practiced
this thing you know in the great history
of Christianity which trials are a
little bit of an odd thing but
it it raises this question
you raised this question which is would
you know a witch if you saw one you
don't look like a witch no but you were
practicing would you I don't know yes
would you really no
the answer to you're right don't you're
making me you're provoking some good
good stuff here Michael no you wouldn't
and isn't that a great part of the
deception though isn't that a great part
of the devil's plan right to use people
that just hey girl next door guy next
door really nice people that really just
want to help you really compassionate
people hey they must it must be okay
then because now we look back we say
obviously those women weren't witches I
think first of all
you don't know that right right and I'm
not advocating for uh Witch Trials
necessarily but uh but you one you don't
know that they that they weren't witches
and the other thing is you person in the
Modern Age you don't believe in
witchcraft or at least you tell yourself
you know you're not conscious of this
they all did
right really everyone for all of human
history until about five seconds ago
believed in such a thing as witchcraft
but the people at the time the accusers
and the Accused at the time of the Salem
which they did believe in that and I
don't know the fact that everyone
for all of history everywhere on Earth
has believed in this kind of a thing
that's such a good point and now you're
seeing people literally like hey I'm a
Capricorn oh oh I'm not a I don't do
witchcraft I was just like what that's
so Pisces of you to think that I'm a
witch hold on wait I can't be with you
because our signs don't match up I don't
think so I don't think your chakras are
making you accuse me but I'm not in
witchcraft
all right bye I've got to go get on my
broomstick now
so many people have the blinders on now
you make such a great Point people
really did know
um and you think about so is that being
um pushed out you think because the
Bible and Christianity I mean we we see
where the devil is on the rise I mean we
could see that through I mean come on I
mean between the Grammys and all these
concerts and these Satanic rituals oh
that's just choreography oh you're
cooking at the Hillary Clinton campaign
yeah yeah it's weird it's weird because
it's not I'm not accusing Hillary of
being a witch we all know that already
I'm not that's not nice but when those
emails came out from her server her
completely unsecured server it
for me it's Troublesome when major
politicians are engaging in over or
major political apparatics people around
the politicians are engaging over
occultism and Satanism but even for the
person who doesn't believe in any of
this and they think that I'm deluded and
you're crazy and they're watching but
they're still watching this for some
reason I have to ask
isn't it kind of weird like if you don't
believe any of it's real isn't it weird
to go like have a big stew out of a
cauldron with eye of Newt and you know
weird spells being cast out that's at
least an odd thing to do and so also
part of the reason I think that people
are so blind to it is
biblical literacy religious literacy is
just so cratered in recent memory
because we kicked the Bible out of
schools yes that and because of other
problems within the church that I mean I
I heard from a professor very serious
professor at a very serious University
who said most of the students don't know
who Noah is wow
that's shocking I mean I even did when I
was a kid I was born in 77 I mean so
we're really going back but even I did
wow that is that's horrible that really
is but you know too Michael I think that
if you conceded to the fact that God is
real and
um
you would have to give up those things
and those things are offering you
something right am I going off on this
one I don't know like the astrology the
tarot cards all of that that's been
giving you something that you want and
if you if you turn to God and conceded
that that's demonic and that God is real
well then again remember you're coming
to an authority figure and you're gonna
have to give up something that is
keeping been keeping you very
comfortable in your own sin and your own
Pride
so I think that's a reason why you would
want to Oh no you're crazy oh no I'm
just gonna this is fine you know because
religion is about God spirituality is
about you and it also not only is it is
it that you're going to have to give up
some of these fun little
weird powers or whatever
you're also gonna have to give up your
sins that you enjoy yep which I guess I
guess are synonymous or their
significant overlap but you're also
going to have to give up
or
that thing you like to do with that lady
down the street you're also going to
have to give up your greed you're also
going to have to give up that screaming
at your uncle or whatever you know you
just you're gonna have to give up these
things that your drugs and your booze
and you're this or you're that if you've
got a problem with those things uh and
that's you know it's a big ask it when
you cultivate habits
yes it's a big ask but I think that's
where people
um
where we know that God's commands are
not burdensome they're actually set up
for us to live an abundant life which is
amazing so the very thing that they're
seeking for that peace and that freedom
isn't offering any of that but we have
it by giving up those things and and
coming to the Lord right because we we
delude ourselves in a couple ways in
modern atheism and modern religion which
is we say oh the the demons they don't
really give you anything no they do you
actually did have psychic powers yes you
know I mean I I believe that and people
have that you actually did get something
in exchange for your effective worship
of demons and likewise they'll say oh
you know if you're going to worship God
you your will your actions they don't
mean anything you don't have to do
anything you don't need to practice
virtue you don't need to avoid sin you
don't need to grow in Holiness you don't
need to pray you don't you know our Lord
didn't say I there is no yoke or burden
to following me he didn't say forget
leave that crossover on the side and
just follow me or don't whatever he says
take up your cross and bear it and he
says my yoke is easy and my burden is
light but it is a yoke that's right
there is it's a light burden but
you got to do stuff right you know this
is sometimes in modern religion there's
a in all modern religion including in
I'm sorry to say parts of the Catholic
Church they'll de-emphasize liturgy
we're a very very long passages of
multiple books of the Bible talking
about liturgy in the Old Testament
how God wants to be worshiped you think
about the levitical vestments you think
about you think about just the
construction of the Ark of the Covenant
the Tabernacle and it's got to be
exactly like this and it's got to be
exactly like this even in you know one
step removed liturgically you talk about
the construction of Noah's Ark
the Precision with which God says
do this in this way and
it seems to me to come out and say well
it just doesn't matter how you how we
worship God you know we all worship God
in our own way man we're all hugging
different parts of the elephant no well
you know I'm I'm not saying that if you
say a certain prayer in a certain way or
if you kneel in a certain way that there
you are that's yourself obviously I'm
not saying that but if you love the Lord
and you have a relationship with God and
you want to pursue God then
wouldn't a follow-up question be
well how do how does the Lord want me to
worship Him how does the Lord want me to
follow him that but that takes you out
of the realm of spirituality completely
I'll put you back in relatively out
complete now you even care that there's
that God wants anything when you even
care you're so out of new age you're so
out of spirituality yeah if you even
care but now you know I don't know if
you've heard of Christ Consciousness yes
I have so I've people have brought this
up I don't really know what it is so
Christ Consciousness is when you uh will
take some of the teaching of Jesus
Christ you know the fun loving like the
fun the loving mushy part of Jesus I
mean the peaceful he's just peace and
love you know okay but also means to you
man yeah exactly
yeah you know
and then you'll go practice yoga and
also worship Buddha it's so hey you know
whatever you want to do and it's just
this idea that you can worship more than
one God and just take
um that's completely rejecting the uh
Jesus's identity as the Son of God who
he is and once again it just goes back
to you doing you and after all right
don't we live in that love is love and
you do you do you know where I first
heard the phrase Christ Consciousness
from a bomb in New York late at night
really I just gotten into the city I
went to pick up some food at McDonald's
I run into this bum and I'm just
chatting with the bum you know eating
hamburgers and he was had an interesting
conversation and he started going off
about
achieving Christ Consciousness wow and I
and I thought you know this is the
perfect topic for the ravings of a of a
an addicted probably deeply mentally
Disturbed bum this is not you can
forgive a guy who is
that mental disposition perhaps for
going off the deep end but then you hear
it from people who yeah seem like they
should have their Affairs in order but
it
is the idea that it just
takes the agency away from the actual
Christ and just puts it on your Gnostic
ability to yeah learn secrets and
control the universe is that basically
yeah and it's really subjective so
you'll have different people describing
it differently
um some will describe it as
um well we're all children of God and we
know that's not the truth We're All Made
In His Image but we're not all his
children
um trying to raise the vibration getting
that level of Enlightenment and
connecting with your own Divinity oh
Your Divine are you
my divinity
into my flesh here I know and it comes
back to that baby God thing again you
know wanting to have that power and be
Godlike that's really what it comes down
to and
um so like I said anything in the new
age it's really subjective you know
um all the things you know the astrology
the numerology the
um angel numbers all that type of oh
yeah oh
oh it's all out there Michael it's it's
it's horrible I know we're over time but
what's an angel number it's not really
an angel number it's just a number that
um you people see numbers right and
apparently our brains actually will pay
attention to patterns of numbers but
then you go to Google I keep seeing 11
11. I keep seeing four four four there's
my x 777 right and then you're going to
get a list of new age explanations for
that and one is going to be that it's an
angel number and Angel is communicating
with you with a message through that
number okay especially if you're seeing
it all the time I just turned my phone
it's 11 11 on the stove right
but the um the explanations will be
subjective because they're being
channeled by different mediums different
you know one might say
um you're an ascended Master one might
say the angel is trying to tell you you
know whatever I don't know that you're
at peace or something then people will
see numbers on license plates that were
mom's birthday or whatever and then
maybe Mom just recently passed away
Mom's communicating with me through the
license plate and and I understand the
pain Michael I got as many readings
probably as I gave I mean I've had
tremendous loss in my life so my heart
goes out to people that agree this of
course and that then they're not wanting
that connection to be
gone
they're wanting to keep something going
they want to keep something going and
they want to keep connecting
communicating with the person you lost
we will get that anybody who suffered a
great loss right
but that's just not the truth and once
you go down that road you're going into
demonic destruction and that's the whole
thing like you will get that oppression
right right it's so it's so much more
Insidious because I you know I'll mock
the people who want to make themselves
Masters of the Universe and so I'm
manifesting whatever I want because I
control I'm God actually but you know a
lot of it is just you know if someone's
mom died and she's really sad and just
she sees a little you know bird fly out
the window and thinks so is that yeah
you know maybe that's is that really my
mother or I don't know there's oh did I
hear some did I see something did I do I
go to a medium it's comes from from
desperation yeah and uh because because
we all crave that but uh you know I at
least believe
I'll see
I hope all of my loved ones someday at
least a good number of them I hope
um but it's not going to be
by talking to you it's going to be you
know the resurrection of the dead and
the life of the world to come
Jen an absolute pleasure I've kept you
late you're going to miss your flight
and then we'll probably keep talking for
the rest of you thank you so much for
being here working people find you thank
you for having me
www.xpsychicsaved.com
that's me include the X don't go that's
right ex yes that's right do not do not
go to the current ones and everything's
linked there all of my social media
platforms my podcasts
um podcasts you got to give it a listen
Michael we got it all on there
numerology astrology it's great
getting out there okay I can't I guess
it's better to know
as long as it won't tempt me no because
you'll give them you'll get the full
picture yeah Jen thanks for being here
thank you Michael
foreign